dude i remember i used to play these
have this place in st louis the funny
bone over there
so it was a comedy club man and the
first
the first show was no smoking right this
the late two shows dude those [ __ ]
were smoking
bro i remember bruh like dog i didn't
know if there was
nine people in there or a [ __ ] nine
thousand
there was so much smoke it was seven
foot ceilings
trust me and no uh no uh i don't even
think they had a damn system to get the
smoke out
they had a frickin i swear to god they
had a waitress by the window with the
window open just waving a menu at it
like
they didn't have a damn game plan bro
and i couldn't tell you bro if it was a
damn
i swear at one point i saw a damn boat
go through the mist i didn't know what
was going on
i said it is [ __ ] thick in here
but i would just still do my shows i had
cancer by that second show but i kept
doing them boy
i was in remission by the second day i
was there i was in remission
did you ever smoke cigarettes oh yeah i
used to smoke a man i smoked for
probably about 16 years yeah
i did about the same thing do you miss
smoking it sometimes i miss some of it
not at all
how bad did it get for you um i never
was a heavy smoker i
at my i would always smoke when i drank
and so at the very most i was maybe a
pack a week
that's not bad you know so it wasn't bad
at all but um
i got bronchitis in um i think it was
and i went to the doctor and he said man
he said i don't give a [ __ ] if you start
back
immediately but you've got to quit
smoking for at least three weeks
and i thought to myself well if i can
quit for three weeks man i can quit
completely yeah and then uh
ever since then i'm not completely
tobacco-free i i still dip
every now and then you know yeah i
couldn't dip good man
yeah well the good thing about dipping
is nobody's ever died from secondhand
spit
[Laughter]
well i don't i mean who knows what's
going on in some places who knows what's
going on some people real caught up in
some wild [ __ ] but
uh dude i remember when i was young we
went the first
time we got a can of dip man it was like
cherry skull or something yeah
and my buddy had got his driver's permit
in louisiana they gave it to you at 15
man they gave you that bastard at
15. and it didn't even have a picture of
you it literally had a drawing of you on
it i was like damn that [ __ ] looks
sketchy as hell and uh
my buddy got his mom's car and we got a
can of cherry skull dude and that was
our night bro we didn't even
we was just hitting puberty man so we
didn't even know nothing about really
women we knew about him but we weren't
thinking about it right
exactly so we went out man and i got
sick on it right
and i puked out of my buddy's driver's
side window then i got so sick i said i
need to sit in the back
i puked out of each window in the back
okay look
so in the morning my buddy his mom came
back in town or whatever
she sees the car and there's vomit out
of it all three windows
so she said who you went out with some
kind of party and he said
look i went out with theo he got sick he
just vomited out of all three windows
his mom to this day don't believe him
she said what kind of maniac would vomit
out of three different windows
that'll make you do it it was fun
especially the first time oh yeah
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one
you